[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt's ein finnisches Gebäck ich
kann es echt nicht aussprechen und ich
werde es auch nicht probieren hier
stehts wie man es schreibt und zwar ist
es ein Kardamom Gebäck es sieht so ein
bisschen aus wie Hamburger Franzbrötchen
ist aber ein bisschen weicher und
erinnert so ein bisschen an
Zimtschnecken aber eben mit dem Gewürz
Kardamom das ganze ist ein luftiger
Hefeteig und wir haben es in Lappland
gegessen ich erzähle euch später noch
eine Geschichte dazu jetzt mache ich
erstmal den Hefeteig dafür nehme ich
einen Würfel Hefe zwei Esslöffel warmes
Wasser 80 g Zucker 500 g Mehl Weizen
oder Dinkelmehl könnt ihr da nehmen etwa
250 ml Milch jeweils einen Teelöffel
Salz und Kardamom der ist bereits
gemahlen ein Ei ein Eiweiß und 100 g
weiche Butter ja das erste was ihr
machen könnt ist wirklich die Hefe in
der Schüssel zu zerbröseln
und da könnt ihr jetzt frische Hefe
nehmen oder auch gerne Trockenhefe und
wenn ihr ein bisschen länger Zeit habt
dann könnt ihr auch die Hefe Menge
reduzieren lass dann einfach den
Hefeteig länger aufgeben also je weniger
Zeit ihr habt umso mehr Hilfe nimmt man
den in dem Fall und für 500 g Mehl ist
ein Würfel Hefe okay man kann aber auch
die Hefe Menge reduzieren wenn man sagt
man mag den Hefegeschmack nicht so
deswegen entscheidet ihr das ruhig
selbst hier noch Zucker mit rein dann
kurz verrühren
[Musik]
dann gebe ich jetzt hier schon mal das
Mehl dazu
ich habe jetzt hier das Dinkelmehl
benutzt das 630er oder ihr könnt auch
ein Weizenmehl nehmen dann Milch dazu
und ich habe jetzt hier schon mal
gemahlen Kardamom ihr könnt aber auch
Kardamom Kapseln nehmen das sind die
hier dann macht es nämlich so dass ihr
die Kapsel öffnet und diese Samen
rausnehmt die zermahlt und dann im Teig
dazu gibt aber ich hatte jetzt auch noch
gemahlen da deswegen benutze ich den
einfach und gebe die Zutaten alle
nacheinander dazu die Butter immer zum
Schluss damit die nicht direkt auf die
Hilfe kommt weil dann die Hefe nicht
mehr so gut wirkt
[Musik]
und jetzt schön für etwa 10 Minuten lang
kneten entweder mit der Küchenmaschine
oder mit den Händen das geht auch gut
so ist ein bisschen einfacher
[Musik]
ist der Teig fertig wenn er bei euch
auch noch so ein bisschen zu weich ist
kann es sein dass ihr vielleicht auch
ein bisschen mehr Mehl braucht also so
ein zwei Esslöffel aber ich warte immer
gerne ab bis ich sehe wie sich die
Konsistenz verändert wenn man nämlich
direkt am Anfang zu viel dazu gibt dann
kann sein dass er zu fest wird und jetzt
am Ende nach 10 Minuten sehe ich okay
ein bisschen weich ist er noch ein
bisschen was gefehlt
aber so wird er perfekt
[Musik]
so sieht der Teig super aus
und dann nehme ich den jetzt hier
erstmal raus
[Musik]
ich glaube es gibt keinen Teig den ich
mehr Liebe als Hefeteig Hefeteig ist
echt schön jetzt könnt ihr euch so ein
bisschen backtrennspray nehmen einmal in
die Schüssel und auf die Hand
und dann den Teig schön zu einer Kugel
formen
und dann lasse ich ihn nämlich abgedeckt
jetzt war eine Stunde bei Raumtemperatur
ruhen oder ihr könnt das ganze in die
Kenwood zurückgeben da kann man ja die
hitzefunktion mit Einschalten so auf
ungefähr 34 Grad oder sogar im
Dampfbackofen auch bei 34 Grad mit
gärstufe da trocknete Teig auch nicht
aus also hier muss ich jetzt gleich ein
bisschen Fett noch drauf sprühen oder
ihr gebt eine Schicht Mehl drauf schön
abdecken und ruhen lassen und dann kann
ich gleich schon mal die Füllung
vorbereiten
für die Füllung habe ich hier schon 100
g weiße Butter 50 g braunen Zucker etwas
Zimt und Kardamom und zum Bestreichen an
Eigelb und etwas Hagelzucker hier könnt
ihr jetzt gerne den Zucker mit Zimt
vermischen und Kardamom dazugeben wie
gesagt wenn es euch zu viel mit Kardamom
wird dann lasst ihn hier gerne auch weg
aber es gehört halt zum Gebäck dazu also
die haben schon in Lappland auch stark
nach Kardamom geschmeckt und ich fand es
echt gut ich fand es echt super auch mal
so eine Abwechslung zu normalen
Zimtschnecken bei mir ist der Hefeteig
jetzt schon aufgegangen
das heißt ich nehme den jetzt hier raus
guck dir mal wie schön
ich liebe einfach
so schön
bisschen Mehl auf die Arbeitsplatte
man könnte das zu einem schönen großen
Rechteck ausrollen
[Musik]
dann nehmt ihr euch jetzt hier die
weiche Butter und bestreicht den Teig
damit
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt der Zucker drauf
wenn ihr da jetzt so wie ich braunen
Zucker nimmt dann habt ihr direkt diese
dunkle schöne Farbe und brauner Zucker
schmeckt auch immer so ein bisschen
malziger deswegen passt es echt schön
[Musik]
und dann jetzt hier diese Teigplatte
schön aufrollen es könnte auch immer
gerne mit Hilfe der Matte machen
[Musik]
und ich gebe da jetzt noch mal so ein
bisschen Mehl drumherum
[Musik]
möchtest du eine riesenrolle geworden
und jetzt schneidet ihr diese Rolle in
kleine Scheiben aber schneidet sie nicht
gerade sondern immer einmal so und
einmal so dass so eine Art Trapez
entsteht das sowieso eine Dreieck fast
schon aber wie gesagt ein Trapez am
Anfang schneide ich es hier weg
dann hier
denn dann habt ihr hier diese Form
und dann bemehlt ihr das ganze noch mal
stellst auf und könnt dann mit dem
Messerrücken oder mit einem
kochlöffelrücken hier so reindrücken
also praktisch wie bei
wie heißen sie
Franzbrötchen wie bei Franzbrötchen
und ich weiß noch ich habe damals
vergessen das ganze umzudrehen und habe
die so zerdrückt und war und habe mich
irgendwie gewundert warum das nicht so
nach außen quält und dann ist mir
eingefallen oh stimmt ich habe es
vergessen zu drehen
[Musik]
Pinsel hier so ein bisschen noch das
Mehl runter das möchte ich nicht
mitbacken und dann bestreiche ich die
Teilchen mit Eigelb
das ist Eigelb was übrig ist vom Teig
aber nicht auf der Schnittfläche sondern
wirklich nur da oben und da streue ich
dann Hagelzucker drauf und da
Hagelzucker ist echt auch sehr wichtig
also obwohl ich jetzt nicht so der
zuckerfan bin sage ich mit dem
torten-channel obwohl ich jetzt nicht so
der zuckerfan bin was so ja so so
Übermaß an Zucker z.B ist sagt die die
irgendwie so 5 kg Zucker pro Torte nimmt
egal ihr wisst was ich meine ich nehme
nicht so oft gerne zu viel Zucker in
solchen Gebäck aber der Hagelzucker hier
ist schon wichtig
ach das klappt ja doch kein Mensch
bitte ist wichtig weil er echt da drauf
gut schmeckt kennt auch jedes Eigelb so
ein bisschen mit Wasser strecken dann
lässt sich ein bisschen besser
verstreichen
[Musik]
jetzt sind sie schon fertig für den
Backofen den Ofen habe ich jetzt noch
nicht angemacht ich stelle die jetzt
praktisch in den kalten Ofen schalt ihn
dann an denn dann hat es Gebäck noch
Zeit während der Aufheizzeit im Backofen
einfach auch schön aufzugehen das heißt
jetzt beide Bleche gerne bei Heißluft
z.B in Ofen stecken oder gerne auch
nacheinander falls es nacheinander backt
dann solltest du jetzt einen Blech
abdecken damit ich hier bei
Raumtemperatur aufgehen kann das andere
heizt mit dem Backofen vor und nutzt
eben diese Aufheizzeit und dann werden
wir danach das Gepäck
ich bräuchte jetzt draußen auch so eine
finnische Kälte und Lagerfeuer aber wir
essen es einfach dann frisch und warm
und dann wird es auch schön
[Musik]
jetzt ist das geweckt fertig und hier
drinnen riecht auch richtig gut und wenn
es gutes Essen gibt ist klar dann kommt
nicht weit
was wir am Lagerfeuer gegessen haben
35 Grad minus 35 Grad und das krasse war
dass die gefroren waren also wir mussten
die wirklich am am Lagerfeuer grillen
und vom Aussehen her sehen die aus wie
diese Brötchen bei Ikea also ich weiß
nicht ob das jetzt Finnisch oder ist
schwedisch oder könnt auch schwäbisch
sein weil wir würden im Schwabenland
dazu sagen nusshörnle oder holzbrötchen
wobei Franzbrötchen ja
das schmeckt karamelliger und das
schmeckt halt schon stark nach Kardamom
ja also ich weiß nicht völlig egal wer
es erfunden hat wir probieren es erstmal
ohne zu grillen muss ich sagen
oh mein Gott
ja ich grüße den ähm
adipositasverband in Reutlingen
lassen sondern wirklich direkt gebacken
und die gehen so wundervoll auf also ich
finde auch vom Aufwand her nichts Großes
und ihr könnt sie auch gerne einfrieren
und dann einfach nur mal bei Bedarf
aufbacken das geht auch gut wir haben es
ausprobiert am Lagerfeuer für euch und
deswegen haben wir festgestellt dass mir
gut auch aufgewärmt schmeckt gut da
karamellisiert der Zucker noch mal schön
ja wenn das nicht aufgegangen ist dann
geht es zumindestens auf wenn es
gegessen habe und zwar ihr geht auch
wahrscheinlich aber richtig lecker muss
mir ehrlich sagen weil das auch noch
cool wäre ich weiß ob das wieder typisch
deutsch ist wenn mir so eine Jacke
ich vermisse jetzt gerade diese diese
Zuckerglasur drüber aber die haben
Zucker ah okay aber wir können trotzdem
ein bisschen Zitronensaft nehmen ein
bisschen Puderzucker rein und dann
drüber sind auch nicht schlimm erinnere
ja aber ich habe dir beim Bäcker geholt
ja und zwar hieß es damals in Dortmund
Hausen Simone Speck und die haben die
traumhaftesten nusshörnle gehabt ja aber
die gibt's leider nicht mehr es war eine
griechische Bäckerei eigentlich und war
echt cool schade ja also aber echt
lecker gerne zum Nachmachen einfach auf
auf dem Blog vorbeischauen oder in der
App da findet ihr das Rezept und ich
muss sagen dass mich dieses Gebäck jetzt
einfach immer an unserer lapplandreise
erinnert ja oder ein Ikea
[Gelächter]
tschüss tschüss
[Musik]